I'm outside New York Times editor says
it was a mistake to Cave to the woke mob
James Bennett breaking his silence after
he was forced to resign for a green
lighting and op-ed by Republican senator
Tom Cotton which called for sending in
troops to quell the black lives matter
Riots of 2020. Bennett says a liberal
paper badly wants to welcome the left
and his boss quote blew the opportunity
to make clear that the New York Times
doesn't exist just to tell progressives
how progressives should view reality
that was a huge mistake and a missed
opportunity for him to show real
strength that happening as trust in the
media is near a record low just 34
percent of Americans trust the press to
report the news fully accurately and
fairly so do you remember this judge
when this happened it caused a huge Fury
that's right or Fury yes okay we were
just having that debate yes how do you
pronounce that word and thank well done
thank you you've moved well to the
English language yeah
[Laughter]
you know I remember it was lunacy it was
like you know they've got Putin who was
this madman who's killing Innocents kids
in schools you've got the Taliban they
can put out essays but you can't have a
United States Senator putting out an
essay because they said that Senator Tom
Cotton fudged the facts about antifa now
he didn't fudge the facts about antifa
if you remember Congressman Jerry Nadler
said antifa was a myth there isn't even
an antifa but what this has done is it's
made it clear that the that the New York
Times made the left to totalitarianism
and a dictatorship and if you don't
think and speak the way they do forget
the old gray lady she's dead and buried
they're on to the walksters with the
earrings and whatever else it's over and
and you know the the simple topic was
his opinion based on a law and a statute
and they denied that and they claimed
that it put black staffers in danger at
the New York Times crazy and so he got
fired Pierce I thought this was at the
time one of the most insane stories I'd
ever covered and reading his account now
makes me even more enraged by it here
you have a bunch of unelected wokies
lurking in the bowels of the New York
Times Newsroom who think they have a
greater right to decide what appears in
the supposedly impartial newspaper then
an elected senator of the United States
and I found the absolutely astonishing
that they were able to wield that power
and as a result this editor then gets
fired fired for having the audacity to
allow an elected Senator to have an
op-ed piece in the paper bullied into it
by a weak management who unfortunately
fell foul to this new cult and I I speak
from personal experience I know what
it's like when this woke mob piled
pressure on their bosses the correct
response is for the bosses to say we
note your concern and we're going to
carry on doing what we want to do
because we believe in free speech this
was an unbelievable suppression of free
speech by the New York Times shame on
the management the fact this guy got
fired is an absolute disgrace and the
fact that that woke mob in that Newsroom
felt that's what journalism is that they
can decide what kind of op-eds appear as
you say When Vladimir Putin and the
Taliban had been given space in those
pages a complete disgrace there's a Fox
News uh poll basically said majority of
registered voters say the media is a
threat to democracy sorry that was the
New York Times poll and here's a
question do you think each of the
following is a major threat to democracy
well mainstream media hit up 59 yeah
it's hard to get 59 of people to agree
on anything higher than Trump it's not
funny they've been saying that Trump's
the biggest threat and it's ended up
being them and I get thousands of text
messages for Jesse Waters prime time
they come in and we read them and we
don't let them affect the show we get
people that I put on guests and they say
I never want to see that guest on your
show again mostly about Piers Morgan
and I don't ban Piers Morgan from prime
time yet and if I did that would be a
corrupt move so if we had listened
to the guy that wrote the op-ed we would
have saved lives we would have saved
billions in dollars of property damage
after those riots rage throughout the
entire country all summer so
instead of like 50 migrants but they
didn't want to mobilize the guard to
save our cities
they fired the guy that put out an op-ed
about how to stop the riots and then
they endorsed a presidential ticket who
was bailing out rioters the people fell
for the Russia hoax those reporters are
still inside the building but this guy
who ran an op-ed is out the door it
doesn't make any sense he's and he's
still he's pretty mad about it he was he
was saying basically
treated like trash yeah the one of the
things you gotta remember about the woke
it's not just the people with the
opinions it's the people who won't stand
up to them and that's often the bosses
whether they're at Disney or at the New
York Times or or uh Nike or ESPN their
their staff is more offended by words
than a thug murdering a black sheriff in
front of a in front of a pawn shop
that's the lesson here is that again the
importance or the danger of their
feelings Trump's actual practical
suffering of real people and we you know
the solution to all this is they gotta
there's got to be a return to some form
of blue collar journalism because right
now all you get is one kind of
journalist or one kind of journalist
Enterprise and it's this brainwashed
hyper leftist hyper snotty elitist that
looks for racism and sexism under every
rock that is their prison their filter
therefore they can't see the violence
they don't see what happens it's
violence they see January 6th as
violence one rare day when a bunch of
people in Red Hats acted up is far worse
than the dozens of people that were
murdered and killed on the streets and
injured yeah the police precincts burned
yeah and it doesn't matter whether you
agree with cotton or not actually
this debate should not be about whether
you agree with what he wrote or not it's
about as right as a U.S senator to
express his opinion in the New York
Times I remember that's it I remember we
interviewed him the next morning after
that and he was so bewildered to me was
like wait what what just happened I
thought this was America yeah right I
had Kamala Harris trying to right the
ship with another staff shake-up yes
it's a Wednesday so that means there was
a staff ShakeOut up but is it too late
there's a different Democrat in high
demand I want to Brian Kilmeade I want
you to do me a favor I want you to click
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page this is the only way that I know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now